bon ça va la petite bourgeoisie du cube
on a cliqué parce qu'on a envie de voir
le petit squeeze se faire torturer
hockey non mais tranquille mais aucune
répartie aujourd'hui nous sommes avec
lâcheté ses vaches que vous connaissez
extrêmement bien et on va jouer à l'un
des premiers jeux auxquels on avait mais
je crois que c'est le premier jeu auquel
on a joué en réalité virtuelle
ce qui fait très bien d'accord donc ça
ça veut dire va te faire [ __ ] en
langage de dinosaures cros et là le jeu
est certes sur steam il ya un second
niveau
le dessert attention à trop épique à
l'accouchement en cuisine
space to select c'est parti alors le but
je me suis lassé de reste appuyé sur
deux touches du clavier et avait toutes
sortes de trucs qui venait te torturer
la gueule ce jeu peut te rendre anxieux
ne ba voila moi je peux le temps du
réinvestissement c'est parfait aux [ __ ]
ingérence trucks avait bras puisque j'ai
exactement la même position il est pendu
ce bureau icap vous le proposez pas
celui-là il faut juste rester appuyé sur
les deux touches contrôle de ton clavier
et ne jamais retiré tes doigts sinon tu
perds instantanément alors attention
alors est-ce que je suis un pro je crois
que contrôle celle-là non faussée par
bayer mais c'est pas sûr touch control
c'est parti un scorpion way sur
wikipédia bien sûr un point qui va
arriver il va sortir d'où il va sortire
doué je veux juste le voir arriver
tu vois arriver tout va bien se passer
j'ai peur du scorpion il joue le
champion mais qu aux caisses qui fait
une danse c'est une danse du ventre du
scorpion ça bouge bougez bougez bougez
dégage dégage
allez vas t'en as laissé pour la blague
est finie on a compris c'était hyper
amusant pour mutu qui la f4 à je pense
qu'il appelle ses potes et vers la place
qu'après qu'il va arriver là tout
l'osar allo le monde idéal on rigole
bien fort [ __ ] je peux pas sur ce je
vais mais je suis dans le coin ce [ __ ]
d'aigle à ces bruits de voir comme une
énorme merde alors ensuite haye
yep qu'est-ce qu'il ya america d'ischia
mange le met toi bien cousin c'est
wikipédia qui régale aujourd'hui bon
pour le monde ça se passe très bien je
suis hyper heureux je m'attendais à 1000
fois bien au je n'aime pas trop ça mais
en vrai j'aime bien et ça prend ça me
fait toujours un petit peu près normal
mais j'adore les serpents voilà la
passion bizarre de luca au char à rabat
s'est pas bien je sais pas s'il est mené
mais au fond je sais pas ce qui me vaut
au wawel
elle vole le mec il est au dessus il est
carrément au dessus c'est le serpent
d'harry potter bouille à l'huile à une
chouette monde un serpent bataille mais
veulent qu'ils arrêtent a indiqué j'ai
envie de le frapper un coup de coude à
danser le micro ils rentrent dans
wikipédia alors par contre tu es sur un
page scorpion sur l'attention c'est à
cause de gens comme toi que tu peux dire
des fois c'est un peu foireux ouais
dominguez se taper des barres de ouf
qu'est-ce que vous avec ça à saint grat
du coup à samedi ça me gratte là ça me
pique mes proches mes tétons amechtane
picchia l'éthique qui me fait mal nous
devons en tirer
ils vont faire spawn un truc de ouf qui
sont dans de faire alors les gars à
choisey besoin de lunettes
on a pas mal de talent nous coule sur
terre vous pourrez les voir je vais vous
n'êtes pas sur moi j'ai fait mon choix
sur moi les gars là est tout le respect
que je vous dois vraiment rien ça marche
pas au cpo faut c'est joli et didon
c'est un poids cela auquel elle sent bon
ben voilà ils nous ont juste fait qui
fait un petit peu avec les feux
d'artifice d'outreau terre c'est bon ah
c'est fini ça se ferme il s'en vend à
plus d'égards mais pourquoi ramener un
si gros truc pour faire un si petit truc
franchement mec c'est un peu démesuré
les gars si vous êtes faire grève on va
ramener une soucoupe volante pour faire
voler trois qui se passe qu'est ce qui
se passe à ça qu'ils ont fait ok c'est
ça qu'ils ont fait il ya un tube tu vas
sortir
à cet égard aux sommes au moulias il ne
soit le cas il est on devait aller et
après cela il me mange victoire je parle
pas du prénom voilà j'aurais pas dû la
faire cela c'est dès la fin de cette
vidéo sur don't let go c'est hyper
marrant de refaire plusieurs années plus
tard le deuxième niveau du tout premier
jeu qu'on ait fait arrêter virtuel
finalement donc y avait bel et bien un
poil qui s'était coincée dans mon
t-shirt pour devrait y arrive pas ya une
sorte de truc là qui colle et ça colle à
mespaul c'est incroyable ce que je
raconte mais c'était pas mal d'eau ça
vous a plu comme d'habitude moi j'adore
ce système de rist appuyer sur les
touches de son clavier et à plein de
trucs affreux qui viennent torture il
faut pas que tu retires tes doigts c'est
un excellent challen à l'atout de la
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
portez vous bien sûr de mon mobile était
fertile celui-là